we bring in now Senator Lindsey Graham
from the great state of South Carolina
senator you were extremely outspoken
today about what was happening in
Washington versus what we now see
unfolding live at this very moment which
is Kim jong-un President Trump now
negotiating the denuclearization of the
entire peninsula thoughts mr. Shreck is
disrespectful to President trumpet
undercut our foreign policy I talked to
President Trump last night he didn't
appreciate very much having this hearing
Holly's trying to get the North Koreans
to give up their nuclear arsenal I can
only imagine if we'd pull this done what
would be happening to us on every major
network in the company a country so very
disparate I may if I can there is so Kim
jong-un and the president they spent
about well 34 minutes or 37 minutes
alone together as that Henry just told
those moments ago that they're now going
to bring in ed their teams these are
their interpreters walking with them
this is the pole at the historic
Metropole Hotel and they are gonna be
walking over to the expanded group in
there they are as we said a Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo and his counterpart
very inside we expect maybe someone like
Mick Mulvaney John Bolton who we saw
waiting just off stage left there a
moment ago might join as well so this is
they're just about almost on time they
were talking about 9:45 a.m. local time
here 9:45 p.m. Eastern back home that
they would be having what they call an
expanded bilateral meeting you know I
don't know pictures if you can interpret
it but a lot of smiles a lot of
personnel look you can see Kim Jocelyn
is role seems very relaxed it's very
cordial president said a few moments ago
when reporters were there
I wonder if chairman Kim is willing to
say what he said to us at dinner last
night I'm gonna let him decide whether
he's gonna say publicly he didn't quite
get there he just said something very
general chairman Kim about how he
expects positive results but you can
clearly read that president Trump you'll
have a chance in the interview to ask
him suggested that at dinner last night
chairman Kim went much further in
private than he has in public you know a
lot of times Dan buns you know a lot of
these things as you can see they're now
walking
in with the Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo and his counterpart from North
Korea often times they were
predetermined outcomes sure not
necessarily here except for maybe ending
the Korean War yeah matter of fact most
of the time bottom-up diplomacy is
exactly how it occurs you have
lower-level bureaucrats lay out the
groundwork for a meeting before it ever
gets to the level of president he's
taken it in a different direction he
said we're gonna handle this from the
top let me go back to Senator Lindsey
Graham back in Washington we it's so
deep and it's so profound senator yeah
the potential that what can happen here
right look I'm not Pollyannish we know
that we've got to have this has got to
be a verified deal there's got to be
open access and inspections on demand or
else is not going to work for anybody
right but it's important
yeah well the question is why are we
having this meeting I mean why is Trump
meeting with North Korea when North
Korea wouldn't meet with anybody else I
think president Trump rattled North
Korea I think they believe that
President Trump would use military force
to stop their nuclear missile program if
he had to he took them seriously and
Trump's giving them a way out
chairman Kim if you're smart you'll take
the way out given to you by President
Trump if you're actually trying to play
the guy you're going to regret this
effort you know it's so funny I
mentioned the having known the president
for over two decades you have some
insight into his thinking in my personal
opinion this is just purely speculation
that we were likely just one two three
Rockets away from the United States
taking that out of the air and a major
escalation okay I talked to President
Trump about a couple hours ago right
before he went to meet with the North
Korean leader I talked to him all last
year the fire and fury rhetoric was
sincere it the North Koreans believe
that if they fired another missile they
were going to get attacked they were
going to get attacked and here's what I
would say the president's giving them a
chance to maintain their security
increase their prosperity and in return
he wants them to give up their nukes
this is the last best chance for peace
if this doesn't work we're not going
back to the status quo so everybody in
America and the world should pray for a
good outcome here but the reason that
Kim is at the table he believes that
Trump is hell-bent on stopping him one
way or the other in the best way as they
win-win you know so there's always the
expectations and and damn munch you know
I thought brought up a good point when
Reagan walked away from the table at
Reykjavik yet the media went insane when
Reagan talked about the evil empire they
went insane when Bush talked about the
axis of evil they went insane when he
challenged go over talk to tear down the
wall there seems to be a pattern you
know we've been around too long but
there seems to be this pattern and that
is that the Democrats feel and it's just
I find it double Chamberlin ish in
Pollyannish and naive and frankly
dangerous that somehow if they bribe
dictators and the world's despot Bill
Clinton tried it with Kim Jong Un's
father Kim jong-il
and we know that Obama tried it with the
mullahs in Iran oh if we give you 150
billion dollars in cash and other
currencies maybe you'll like us no
they're still chanting death to America
and threatening to annihilate Israel and
wipe it off the map but strength seems
to get their attention and I believe
that you're right the president
absolutely was believable in the hearts
and minds of the North Koreans and Kim
jong-un all I can tell you is if Susan
Rice gives you some advice mr. president
don't take it the Iraq not worked out
well for everybody and everybody here is
laughing so the bottom line is if a
guy's threatened to cut your throat
don't buy him a knife John Kerry walked
through glass to get a crappy deal with
Iran Trump is smart enough to get out of
that deal and he says I'm not in a hurry
I want a good deal I want a real deal a
real deal of North Korea's they give up
their nukes we end the Korean War and we
have peace and prosperity for everybody
on the pen
a bad deal is to continue for North
Korea to build up their nuclear nuclear
forces and Trump's not gonna let that
he's called the question you wanna move
you want to make the media's head spin
you know what you really want the insane
right now Obama got a Nobel Peace Prize
for nothing just showing up for not now
Bush okay yeah exactly
so imagine let's hope for the best i
thought liberals imagine a world without
nukes are right how about a world with
fewer nukes to start imagine they get
this deal done and it's verifiable on
demand inspections and imagines that are
they gonna have to now meltdown people
may actually have real heart attacks
if somebody says if it happens maybe
Trump gets the Nobel Peace Prize a world
in which would be a good thing for the
world and our kids a world in which
Donald Trump gets the Nobel Peace Prize
is probably probably more dangerous in
the eyes of the Liberals than North
Korea and having nukes but the point is
that he's on the verge of a breakthrough
a hope but he is not gonna let this go
forward the way it's been in the past
either we're going to have peace or
we're eventually going to have a
military conflict I think North Korea
realizes that's the two choices they
have all right senator thank you I know
and you're right about what happened
today what a what a dramatic comparison
how how shallow pathetic and frankly sad
thank you so much for being with us